pawn to c4 let's see how much risk
magnus is willing to take so far he goes
for d5 e6 he's done that a lot recently
playing all kinds of
shady to less shady
he played he played the a6
in this specific position in uh
in his one game against prague that they
played in uh
uh
online last year and that ended up being
a draw
e3 played
so we'll never find out
what magnus
thinks about all that
but we will find out if he just quote
wants a qga or if he wants
to split the difference though if you
play b3
bishop e2 here the position still
remains rocky solid for white
but let's play bishop b3 and follow it
up with e4 against
most moves
in the
in the meantime
pragnanda
has played
7b3
which yeah
is one of the moves i mentioned as
being solid but not exactly going for
the end game there's also just one of
the one of the main lines i don't think
there's any
yeah thoughts about
making a draw against magnus or anything
i think that's just what he
he likes in this position i've also
played this move
and magnus played b6
not the main move as far as i know i
think the likes of nakamura have started
playing this followed by castles and
then later bishop d7 knight c6 if
appropriate or b5 b5 and then some rook
a7 stuff i've seen linear do that yeah
exactly
just mention that i'm openly against
playing in the mask and then we aren't
obliged to do it during the game
according to the regulation the bishop
on d5 probably stays on d5 allowing
black to trade i think we start with by
playing knight c3 uh because rook v8
indicates that black is now ready to
take and play bishop b7 if the queen
takes on d5 so we probably don't want to
be taking with the queen we want to be
taking with the knight
and then developing is
yeah 9595 and you can play b7 you can
play bishop d6 all of these moves are
should be too played
yeah also practice i started to take
time yeah at least
should be two he hasn't blitzed out
pragma against magnus what's going on
here
uh
yep i i quite like uh
[Music]
having having thought about it for a sec
i i quite like prague prague's position
and uh
yeah it's it's one of those situations
where if you if you don't get rid of the
bishop on d5 early you might never have
a particularly comfortable way of doing
it and black is a bit
uh tied up because you you don't
particularly want to play bishop b7
taking on d5 suddenly makes white's
entire position make a lot more sense
doesn't want to go b4 yet because the
knight e4
seemed to
be tough to meet i guess yeah he still
wants to keep his options open maybe now
b4 is more of a threat where he could
then after let's make some stupid move
very briefly uh in the sicilian after
because before h5 is on the board now in
the sicilian
so there's one
line there which we haven't really
discussed
pro okay i figured it out we still
should show it though moving on how's
magnus doing magnus carlsen double s
yeah his uh a4 seemed like it may not
have been the
i think the whole sequence of rook fd1
followed by a4 i think uh
probably playing a4 explains why he
chose the the rook that he chose because
now the rook on a1 is participating in
the game without
needing to be moved from
its starting square but it's a bit slow
and playing on the queen side doesn't
seem
as critical as
so where'd it go wrong
if are you
wrong
and also interestingly apparently magnus
could have played before here and had an
instantly very good position
before followed by why didn't you magnus
yeah
take stakes
and the difference is we apparently we
want to go c5 c4 here against
many ideas no maybe not not in every
single spot but
uh
in a number of positions here c5 c4 with
the pawn on a4 instead of a2
it becomes a much much stronger option
than it was
earlier so you know definitely was a
possibility but h6 is not horrible
h6 is a move which black very often
needs anyway so
understandable that magnus decides not
to
engage in any kind of immediate
calculations
let's go to magnus for a second yeah
there was people were raiding magnus
might magnus's winning chances now
uh the rookie bish buffet maneuver which
i
somewhat joking jokingly referred as the
the spanish maneuver has been played
magnus does like this and also it makes
perfect sense or protecting the pawn on
g7 for any
future trades on the g5 square
the rook now is participating in the
game and also it's much easier to take
on d5 when knight takes d5 doesn't hit
the bishop on e7 but specifically i
think it's before knight a4 knight takes
d5 is
is probably the biggest problem that
prague is now facing
and black has solved all of their
structural problems and magnus does play
before
yeah i had a feeling that
his win yesterday was
so
yeah that was happening
no pregnant that is a tough choice
because neither looks fantastic
yeah
yeah magnus goes with queen e6 which is
uh probably the most concrete move yeah
allows knight c5 but he will win he will
be a pawn up but
i'm guessing from the purely computer
standpoint the fact that you allow the
knight on a4 to get traded for some of
the
much better placed pieces is
enough to consider this an accuracy
pragmata
did not go for
this
this maybe last chance question mark
knight takes c5 giving up a pawn but
getting rid of his silly knight here we
showed the line instead he goes rook to
d1
and now
yeah his position is just too late
strategically very bad and uh
also might be lost by force as uh the
engine seemed to indicate both through
k8 with the id of c5 c4 and apparently
even the immediate c5 c4 with the
intention i guess of meeting ba with rk8
are crushing me strong
apologies
i've heard adjusting plenty but you
probably have more experience than me in
u.s
tournaments yeah
not very much to say there's there's
some reasonably sharp positions here
that could arise
after blex proceeds with the winning
plan of playing c5 c4 for instance but
until prague makes a choice here and
magnus actually has to find the cleanest
winning solution there's really not a
lot to say the position is bad for white
white choices you allow c4 or you give
up the e4 port for absolutely nothing
there but
yeah kind of a strange pairing of
decisions quincy one has been played
tried to stop c4
yeah and the issue for white is that
queen takes e4 actually works here after
rd7 takes takes we can i'm guessing more
than one move wins here even yeah before
here there's rook d4 yeah that's yeah
that's uh that's the problem yeah
so i have to go rook g8 and let's say i
take take and i play h3 why is this so
horrible
it doesn't look that winning doesn't it
at first sight
queen e2 apparently lectures widths
uh
so
even even the the moniker of the suits
is is a
is a misnomer because it's not the suits
it's the trench coat
knight h4 plate
yeah prague are trying to keep the game
going
basically he's now born down with a bad
position at night on the rim and black
having the two bishops
so he needs to swindle
quickly
yeah this is not
this might end no
there's a number of ways for white to
lose a piece while also
getting rid of all the queenside pawns
but because it's
not really an endgame
it doesn't really matter all that much
those positions are completely lost
because you get mated
yeah allowing c3 is never going to be
any kind of a saving grace here
my b6 does feel like a move you make on
two seconds
and now yeah i mean that takes e5 also
wins but i think c4c3 is just such a
confidence
bishop
can never hurt you
you'll kill everything everything often
yeah the game ends
i guess they keep blitzing for a bit
sometimes with this little time also you
just keep making moves on adrenaline
i don't know i it's very hard to even
name a move here you can make
that takes eight queen takes d5 like
every single piece on your in your
position hangs and you're already behind
material i think you do resign here
come on prague knight c8 now we're
talking yeah
okay apparently queen takes d5 is not
even in the top two moves in this
position because knight takes a7 i guess
still completely lost for white but
shouldn't be a very intriguing yeah
i know
i know my
my magnus
just a very very solid solid capture no
need to do anything flashy
knight a7 queen takes a 5 and things
continue hanging
cb2 also not a burden
also not a bad move the end
2595 played knight a7 cb and yeah it's
the same position and you still resign
because
the horse is coming
yeah rugby one there's probably
i mean rook 8 wins rookie 2 wins
whatever you choose yeah it's just
it's a full rook it will just end up
costing why the full rook so
not that not a very
exciting position
all right
you did ask for it here you go
i think it should make you make you feel
better about the whole thing honestly
because you're not you know depriving
someone of their you know hard-earned
way of watching twitch content it's just
throwaways
yep resigned
game over let's go watch
good job by magnus